if we were actually get every kid to
graduate from college you would need a
college degree to be a janitor Bryan
Caplan welcome to a EEI
so your book the case against education
why the education system is a waste of
time and money makes you sort of a
popular guy maybe with an unpopular
argument how's the reception so far well
it's not that unpopular so maybe here's
the books only twenty bucks on Amazon
I've been moving a lot of copies and
I've been getting some very fair reviews
people criticize me but at least they
criticize me for what I said so I got no
complaints okay that's fair all right
well let's jump right in so you start
off in the book and you talk about sort
of three things that education
communicates to employers from three
perspectives can you just sort of break
those down for us yeah sure I say it's a
package of three big trades so first of
all intelligence just that your
education shows how smart you are
secondly SCID also shows how
hard-working you are because you could
be really smart but if you're really
lazy you're not gonna be able to finish
high school much less college and then
last and least obviously I save signals
Conformity it shows that you are willing
to submit to social expectations that
you're going to be an obedient little
sheep right which of course so society
needs obedient little sheep a lot of
times because of everyone we're a free
thinker and free spirit how would
anything get done hold on you've got
this all wrong so you know I learned in
graduate school this human capital
Theory right human couple three we go
two more years of schooling and we get
more benefits and that you know when I
go out on a job market they're gonna say
yeah that guy's got more years of
schooling so that's why I go to school
am I wrong well what you said isn't
literally wrong but you know so the
whole idea of human capital theory is
that education pays because school
poor's useful skills unto you right
so you actually learn how to do that
right and I don't deny that occur
sometime so literacy and numeracy are
very useful skills and if you go to
school to learn computer programming or
something like that then you really are
emerging as a more skillful person and
it makes sense from players who prefer
you but I still say there's a lot of
Education where they aren't teaching it
very much or at least it's not very
relevant to any job you would ever do
and yet employers still seem to care
like why do employers care if you failed
your foreign language classes even
though the people got A's don't speak
the language either right right and I
say the reason is that when you do well
in school you are sending a message to
employers you're saying look I'm the
kind of person who has the package of
brains diligence and conformity to go
and jump through all these hoops so at
least don't throw out my application
when I apply for the job right so in
your book you say let's see I have it in
here you say signaling which is this
theory around signaling has been kept in
a ghetto and this book's goal is to
first emancipate it from the ghetto so
why is it men in the ghetto right so
there are multiple Nobel Prize winners
that have worked on this idea that's
part of what's of why education pays is
just that you're impressing employers
you're getting certified you're getting
a stamp on your forehead you know
there's one economist Michael Spence he
really got his Nobel Prize entirely for
this idea but the strange thing is the
people who look at the real world right
so in what we call empirical researchers
people who study actual schools actual
education the actual labor market have
never been very fond of this idea and
they treat it yeah sure there is this
idea but we're just gonna focus on going
and measuring the payoffs for education
and we really bug me because on the one
hand there's this explanation that seems
to make a lot of sense but the people
look at the real world don't talk about
very much and I wanted to go and bring
theory and reality together and that's
really what this book is all about right
tried to say look there's actually a lot
of empirical evidence a lot of evidence
in the real world that signaling is a
big part of what's going on in education
it's a big part of the reason white pays
and actually there's a lot of facts that
you really just can't explain without
signaling if you didn't believe in
signalling the world would just make no
sense at all all right so we have a
human capital theory which says kids are
learning more and that's why education
is value now we have a signaling theory
that says you know we have these sort of
credentials basically it hinges on
credentials and those credentials are
signals that folks who are hiring in the
labor market say well you know I see
that signal so I know this quality and
these are independent and it seems like
your argument is this certainly a step
beyond signaling it's about empty
signals is that fair well I mean so if
you convince people that you were great
by learning a lot of useful skills then
human capital and signalling will be
almost the same thing but one of the big
puzzles that I talk about in the book is
is why do we spend so much time learning
subjects that almost no one uses on the
job almost no one has a job that uses
history or social science or art or
music or foreign language I mean just
think about all the classes that you
took where you never use them again
after the after the final exam and yet
employers care if you were to say look I
only did the classes what I thought were
useful now give me a job most employers
would not say how the good thinking
instead they wouldn't even be talking to
you because your application would be in
the trash and singly can explain what's
going on here which is even when you
study something useless something that
you don't absolutely absolutely do not
need to know on the job still the fact
that you did it and you jump through
these hoops shows a lot of good things
about you and especially it shows that
you are a conformist person that you
went and followed the norms of our
society you did what your parents
teachers and peers all said everyone has
to do because you're an employer do you
want to hire someone who doesn't do
those things I'd be nervous I mean I
have a lot of nonconformist friends I
love them they're fun but if I were
hiring people I would be scared to hire
those friends I'd hire the boring people
yeah I mean it seems like a safer bet to
hire somebody who's got the credential
than it doesn't but you also make some
serious claims about you know there's
just a lot of waste so paint this
picture for us where's all this waste
and about how much of schooling is
wasted I mean that the subtitle of the
book is ya education system is a waste
of time and money
that's right show me so my preferred
number is 80% of the payoff for our
education is signaling and it's
basically just a waste of social
resources doesn't mean it's a waste for
the individual the individual gets to
look good and outshine at the
competition but is it the kind of thing
that it makes sense for taxpayers to
encourage and that's where I say no I
mean there's a lot of different ways
that you can come at this and I say like
all these different ways point in the
same basic ruff-ruff ballpark of a
number to me probably the most
impressive evidence is you just take a
look at the amount of education I need
to get a job not do a job but to get a
job to be considered worthy of
employment since 1940 the amount of
education that you need to get one in
the same job that your dad or
grandfather had back then has risen by
about three years almost a full degree
right so 1940 there'd be almost no
waiters or taxi drivers or cashiers
with college degrees it would have been
almost unthinkable back then now these
are very common jobs for people with
college degrees to have alright and see
like what's going on I say what's going
on is that the more education the
workforce has the more you need to
impress employers like when every when
almost nobody has even high school
degree then if you have a high school
degree employers say look at this person
this is management material now no one
looks and sees that you finish high
school and says management material
now you might need to have not only
college degree but an MBA so you know
this is called credential inflation it
just means that you know like you know
aside from the fact that jobs have
changed that's happened too right so
there are some more intellectually
demanding jobs but that only explains a
small part of what's going on most of
what's gone on in the economies that you
now need a lot more education in order
to be considered worthy of the very same
jobs that people used to have in the
past right so people I hear a lot of
folks saying you know we have this new
economy it's a new economy and it's the
future economy so kids are gonna need
more and better education and newer
education wrong right oh well it would
be nice if they were being trained for
the new economy but I don't see signs
that schools are doing much of that at
all so you know like the education
system is normally extremely backwards
looking teachers basically teach you the
same things that they were taught when
they were students their teachers do the
same thing to them if you look at the
curriculum the curriculum has barely
changed over time there's a little bit
more time for computer science although
you know as far as I've heard only
Washington state lets high school
students do a computer language instead
of a foreign language all right so
there's almost no adaptation to what
they did what the modern economy is
going on is or is going to be for you
know say like wow like how can we even
get by with this education system I say
the answer is that almost all the actual
useful job training happens on the job
the main thing that you do with your
education is not actually get ready to
do a job the main thing you do is
convince employers that they could train
you in the actual job that they want you
to do right now of course you do learn
some useful things in school and there
are some majors that are more vocational
like nursing or medical school or
engineers or computer scientists but
it's always important to remember that
these are exceptions and that most
students are doing majors in fields
where there's almost no jobs at all and
then you're like well then where do they
get jobs they get jobs in something
outside of their field so like the you
know every year we graduate more new
psychology bas then there are jobs in
psychology and
year we graduate more communications bas
than there are jobs in the entire
entertainment industry so it's not like
people in psychology and communications
never get jobs they just get a job where
the employer says I want someone with a
college degree in something or other
right right and then the reason why the
economy works is that when you finally
get that job then the employer says well
did you learn how to do videography
while doing psychology no well that's
unfortunate but none of your company
embed errors know that either all right
now it's going to it or maybe you did an
internship where you did and then I find
you have an internship that's useful
actually so let me ask you this does
this system work for employers and does
it work well I mean you know if I'm on
the hiring side you know the demand side
of the labor market is it working well
here's the main thing there's about a
trillion dollars of government money in
favor of the status quo every single
year so I wouldn't say the current
system is passed in the market test by
any stretch of the imagination it's
propped up by enormous subsidies and if
government spent a lot less there might
be very different systems to figuring
out who's good for jobs and as bad for
jobs probably be a lot more
apprenticeships probably there be a lot
of other kinds of certification but at
the same time I don't see any sign that
employers are really looking around very
hard for something else you know there
are stories that people say well
employers want to do other things but
it's illegal I did look into the into
this idea in the book like for example a
lot of people say well employers would
do IQ testing for hiring if it were only
legal but since that's illegal they do
college instead so here's the striking
thing when I actually leo did research
on this found out that IQ testing is
like 98 percent legal 2 percent in
illegal 98 percent legal and the amount
of actual punishment that got that you
are likely to receive in the legal
system for doing IQ testing for hiring
is peanuts compared to the cost savings
so I have to say that I don't think that
employers are eager to switch to
something else anything on my story for
this is that if you were to go and say
we're hiring people that dropped out of
high school but they have high IQs I
think you would get a certain kind of
really smart person namely lazy
nonconformist defy it for people who are
again I love them there might a lot of
these are my favorite people in the
world but I don't want to hire them yeah
you don't want to depend on them yeah I
don't want to depend on them I want you
well I can depend upon them to be ready
to go to
on certain moments I said hey hey buddy
hey smart lazy friend do you want to go
to concert free tickets like dude I'm up
for that so yeah so though you know like
depending on them to get your taxes done
exactly them I want the boring person
here I understand so let me ask you a
question it's you're a little bit all
over the map here on which level of
education you're talking about sounds
like you're talking about higher
education and I know that a lot of
people would say yeah I read voices a
ton of money so but you know where does
it stop I mean high school certainly is
always a good investment right well for
the individual then generally it pays
very nicely but again for society I
don't think so so again think about all
the time that you wasted in high school
all the useless requirements things that
you've met that you had to do in order
to graduate that you're never going to
use again I mean it's just very striking
if you make an inventory of all the time
that you spend in high school studying
subjects that you will never use after
the final exam you like massive foreign
language requirement two or three years
and yet almost no one in America learns
to speak a foreign language very well in
school right all right see also history
civics art music these are required
classes to it to an to an insane extent
and yet if you don't jump through these
hoops then you are not going to be
allowed to advance you're not gonna be
allowed to get into college and you're
cutting off a lot of opportunities for
yourself so you know like one of it one
of the other things that I say the book
has be much better if kids especially
kids who just don't like school there
are a lot of kids like that there are a
lot of kids who are miserable bored out
of their minds
you know if kids like this could instead
go and do vocational education or they
could do apprenticeships and be prepared
for an actual job you know it's very
striking that there are countries like
Germany and Switzerland where kids who
just don't like school never have
whether 13 or 14 or 15 they can go and
do vocational education but there's yes
but we have got this education
credential arms race mm-hmm and with
that background right for these kids
it's not a rational decision for them
right I mean the rational decision for
them would be look if you drop out of
high school things are not gonna go very
well am I wrong so if you drop out of
high school and do nothing then you're
totally right if you quit high school
and learn to be a plumber right
especially if you're the kind of person
who probably was going to quit high
school anyway eventually right then I
think there's actually very good
evidence that the vocational track is is
a good idea for
you so the main idea in my book is just
that taxpayers are wasting a lot of
money encouraging this rat race but I do
also have the sight idea that there that
even in high school there are a lot of
kids you know like me oh maybe a third
of kids or half of kids who would
actually be even personally better off
if we a parents would just listen to
them and teachers listen to them and say
look you don't want to do college
College is not is not the kind of thing
that has anything that anyway inspires
either how about we go and teach you
something else and especially I mean
like you know people say look so you get
tagged as a plumber at 13 and say how
about this how about when you're 13 if
you don't like school we introduce you
into 20 different occupations two weeks
as a plumber two weeks as an electrician
just try a bunch of things right is
there anything you like and are good at
at all right and I think there's a lot
of 13 year-olds who would jump at that
chance because like they've spent years
of their life just being told like
you're a C or D student you're not good
at this stuff of shape yeah interesting
so we've had actually the absolute polar
opposite of that as far sort of the
dominant k12 theme over the past Oh
college for all right girls for all and
we should design our education system to
get everybody to graduate high school
and everybody to go to college
it sounds great at this play I mean how
does this play out how do you see this
playing out if we were to succeed in
that what would we have weeks if we were
to actually get every kid to graduate
from college you would need a college
degree to be a janitor you need a
college degree to be a waiter and it
would no longer be in any way impressive
to employers and so employers would then
say you need to have a master's degree
or a PhD or professional degree to be
worthy of even being our intern right so
I mean you're like in a world where
everyone has a college degree then
garbagemen have combat college degrees
then you know the only genome janitors
have college degrees this is a crazy
system but you know it's never going to
happen and we're not even we're nowhere
close to it just cuz even though we
about 70 percent of graduating high
school seniors go on to college but the
actual rate of completion is much lower
yeah right absolutely I mean you know
even two-year college we're having
thirds of our kids not make it through
you know and and and there certainly is
a lot of waste let me ask let me push
back on a couple of things so things
when I was in graduate school I I
learned hierarchical linear modeling I'm
just gonna use as an example because I
ta tit for
yeah I taught it as an assistant and man
you know I really knew every different
way to run it today I need to go back to
my textbooks and sort of review some of
my notes and could sort of brush up on
that but in the in the book you use lots
of examples that are sort of akin to
that not say well I would not be able to
go back and do HLM today without some
review but I can go back and and do it
so in the book you use examples like
well a lot of kids could never pass an
algebra test now and my question is is
that there's something oh yeah adults
write the test they could have passed
when they were kids so my question is
isn't there some value there that isn't
being captured when you say well we've
lost the discrete skills we had in 10th
grade there's a small amount of value so
it's definitely true any educational
psychology will tell you it's easier to
relearn than to learn the first time
around but so much of what people forget
is stuff they never use it never comes
up in adult life and that's why they
forget it actually if you were if you
periodically brush up and refresh your
memory then at least you retain the
basics and yes he is so like you know it
remains useful but some of them out is
really stuff that really adults
virtually never use I mean what's really
was striking to me is that out of adults
who actually went onto calculus as as as
high school students only about 20% even
use algebra on the job right now right
so again it's not like that that's will
restraining people something so that
they can relearn it at each point where
appropriate most of it is just stuff
that you will never encounter again
after the final exam that's why we
forget it so readily is that we have no
additional practice because what was
taught was not really well thought-out
preparation for adult life so getting
even past sort of the discrete skills
that you can relearn how about things
that it can't even be sort of
communicated in skills for instance you
know some people will say well you know
part of getting through high schools
just learn how to negotiate the system
and part of the problem with kids who
drop out is they're never going to kind
of learn to negotiate the kinds of
systems that are gonna give them success
of and
in the labor market so without you know
if we roll back the education system
substantially are we prohibiting kids
are we making it very hard for kids to
learn how to negotiate those systems
right so this is a classic compared to
what question right if it's either
school or play video games home alone in
your basement then school is a great
socializer and I'll say nothing against
it however is that really the relevant
alternative in all other human societies
and earlier in US history the
alternative school wasn't sitting home
alone the alternative was work and work
also teaches people to negotiate systems
and you know teaches social skills
teaches you how to get along with other
people but it also teaches a bunch of
social skills that aren't really being
taught very well in schools today like
accepting criticism right in modern
schools they're so touchy-feely and
they're so positive that kids often are
not told by the way you screwed up you
or not you know your work is inadequate
and you need to improve sorry
right on the job you still get that kind
of thing right now oh yeah so on the job
you learn the idea of you have to make
the customer happy right and life is not
equal or fair these are lessons that are
taught on every job school on the other
hand you really are preparing them for
the strange world that no adult
experiences of equality and fairness so
you don't need a better to go and
prepare kids for the world they're
actually gonna be facing already and of
course don't go and give them immediate
shock therapy where you give them a boss
who screams at them on the first day but
you know just to like just to move them
gradually to a realistic environment
where people don't love you right now so
like teachers at least pretend to love
the students I mean even at the high
school level like they're so nice but in
terms of preparing people for adult life
people aren't going to be that nice
afterwards so you better get used to it
hey everyone thanks for watching part
one of our discussion with Bryan Caplan
part two picks up right where we left
off here so click the link to see the
next part of the series
[Music]